la crise a fait quelque part que mettre
en exergue ce retard comprend en santé
en ce moment en france parce que
pourquoi on est tourné toujours
uniquement par uniquement mais kazim
kazim majoritairement sur le soin le
curatif et énormément sur les hôpitaux
on dit on et hospitalo de centrisme et
c'est tellement vrai il ya beaucoup plus
d'acteurs et ça a été du tout à l'heure
il faut il faut encore élargir pour la
santé c'est beaucoup plus globale que
juste le soin est aujourd'hui les
avancées en santé elles se feront
ailleurs qu'à l'hôpital les plus grosses
en tout cas on parle de prévention s'est
séparé de promotion de la santé
et ça tout ça ça a énormément manqué
dans la gestion de cette épidémie
ce soit de rendre autonome les personnes
un peu plus avec leur santé les c'est ce
qu'on disait il on les perd
madame carole je le dis c'est on était
infantilisante c'est vrai il ya un
paternalisme énorme en santé en france
on n'arrive pas à sortir de ça et et
tous ces éléments là en fait c'est quoi
globalement et je dis pas ça parce que
c'est mon poème mais un petit peu c'est
la santé publique en france on est on
est pas on n'est pas une nation de santé
publique et sans qu'on ne viendra pas eh
bien on va continuer à prendre du retard
par rapport à d'autres pays on trait on
n'arrivera pas à voir des avancées
significatives en santé
[Musique]